to get big big performances but he kind
of faltered he didn't play to his
potential is that because of you know
the nerves we'll wait and see guys but
either way it's going to be the geese
it's going to be the main character
coming out here from khan and shot him
sticking with his main as well at least
so ladies and gents top 8 action here
south asia tlc first match conversation
let's go
of course this is very big this is the
winner's side
whoever wins the set is going to be put
into the winners finals where they will
only have to play in extended central
here now then you want to be in that
comfortable position you don't want to
go into the losers
in the top eight and have to fight as
many matches as you have to get back up
into our grand finals anyways going
right into this let's see how it works
out
khan put it against a difficult position
but he does have the advantage right now
let's see if he's able to make things
happen he needs to work on getting some
of that meter
oh nice punish
interaction
looking to close it out and look at a
very clean opening round round two you
know even though alisa you know i'm i
don't know how you feel i feel like at
least a very very strong character we've
been able to see
uh her skill and and a lot of players
kind of take her really far especially
in these online tournaments um we don't
see that many people use her though
yeah it's very weird i feel like that
she's also one of them characters that
you have to really um be a specialist
with right to perform really well with
her um and that's what we've seen in
many reasons but look at this standing
two right in the back it's gonna hurt
these are gonna really hurt here we go
nice
good answer back i'm loving the side
walking from both guys right now acharya
was able to size at the downford one in
the first round and khan getting all the
way to the back so natural movement on
point
get that out of here man and he's
building up that meter as well
he has a bar almost two
oh here we go
oh my gosh i did so much damage on
pickup
oh nice
i gotta tell you
khan
at first you know
it was quick you know it was one sided
elisa was doing such a great job then
khan just turned things around i blinked
once
and it was three to one in rounds what
happened
yeah i mean uh
these happened man i mean this guy and
and also like really really good uh
movement from from khan he wasn't
stationary he wasn't just back dashing
his side walks really well elisa does
can have some issues sometimes with with
the tracking if you sidestep right and
close um she does have great um great
tracking moves but they weren't used
effectively and khan was able to get
some big damage from those understanding
tools you know it's season three we know
that geese got changed like you said
adjusted and now you know that standing
two can hurt especially if you have some
meter so can't able to find his opening
takes the first match
yeah good stuff so khan one step closer
to getting into our winners uh side
final which is again going to be a very
important position to be in
um man
uh you see characters with do you think
we'll see some adjustments
we're going to see adjustments for sure
we might go to an infinite stage because
every single time i've seen at least a
play if they lose a match they always go
to infinite and i i want to see if
charlotte is going to follow that
pattern because literally every single
time an elisa player knows about what
who they are could be any listed they
will go to infinite and of course it's
because of her amazing back that's her
amazing sidewalk her movement is some of
the best in the game i wonder if
charlotte is going to follow suit and do
the same thing let's have a look i think
he is going to stick with the elisa i
don't think i'm coming and look at that
as i said
it is the um
the infinite yeah
el infinito artix snowfall
yep
come on is this going to work out for
him though and i think this is twofold
you know not only does it have really
good movement but it also gets rid of
that wall pressure and damage that geese
can get with the walls too so an
opportunity for a turnaround
yeah also kind of forcing east to be in
a position where he might have to chase
down alisa overall i don't think that's
a bad tactic and you know alisa has so
many tools especially when it comes to
the range outside of the two range moves
like down three moves like being able to
move quickly running backwards maybe
with a power crush
but we'll see right now
khan is doing a great job but that getup
kick ended up
taking it all round two yep
yeah a big over extension there with the
fourth one plus two so i shot up at the
first round definitely needed that after
that first match
now khan is slowly working his way to
one barometer
and look sharp the way he's actually
approaching you can see the confidence
in his movement he knows exactly how to
approach these
oh my gosh everything's starting to hit
the brake side
oh my goodness
okay no what was that
i don't know what he was going for but
he missed the follow-up
yeah
okay
into the running what's he gonna do
what's the mix he hit him with the back
nice oh side stepped in the wrong
direction if you want to size up against
that down forward one you've got to go
left not right it started gets clipped
[Music]
maybe much like we saw in the previous
match you know it started starting off
very strong winning that opening round
but khan once he gets metered he becomes
much more scary right just keeps in
general becomes much more scary
absolutely yeah and he has that by me
and now one standing two one over
extension one with definitely shot it
could cost him gotta be careful keep it
tight
and khan's already showing it he's
starting to sidestep right trying to
create opportunities for himself gets a
great read there on the parry the follow
up and he's going to close it out oh
guys
has already again really established
that he's not afraid of sidestep yet a
nice sequence on the back into the side
of elisa early on will he be able to
continue that pressure
really mind game right now
figure it out here he's close to another
meter it's gonna change right here he's
gonna have to be careful he does not
want to get an explosion in his face
absolutely man
he's used the bar mia though he's in max
mode can you do something with it
yeah he gets rid of the fireball real
quick so he can start building meter
again i like that play there
okay nice hard to rage oh my god i feel
like once you get stumped out of the
rage drive maybe all over he's gonna
have to make it bigger what's he gonna
do
and he can't do much as kyle is gonna
take him to oh quite comfortably over
the young lad asharib ashara will move
into the losers brackets but khan
winners finals now he is going to be
able to play some first threes from here
on out